now TV I did not know this about you I
don't know you do you play tomb raider
at all
don't be ridiculous no no no but I like
the girl in it
Lara Croft yeah the shorts now have you
played Tomb Raider Meryl what Tomb
Raider I don't even know what you're
talking okay Lisa Laura knows to grow
longer well shut your eyes you grant
because the voice of Lara Croft is
sitting beside you
what yes well that's not me that that's
the voice of the game yes the voice of
Lara Croft is Geeta was now apparently
this got confusing for your son is this
true it did it did when I first started
doing it my son who will kill me
my son who's now 15 but was quite little
and he could never get past the first
stage and so he just make her run around
and sort of swim and rock climbing
things but um she helps she wears his
shorts you know and and see who's doing
that and then he came running and he
said mommy I said how's it going in her
enjoyment he said I like the way the
lady runs the lady with my with mommy's
voice little bit then ban him from
playing bare face
I've spoken to be more dulles and it's
not as simple you don't just say the
lines I mean it takes hours and hours
doesn't it because don't you have to
make every little noise that you might
ever conceivably make yeah well let's
say a person let's call them a fan has
worked together seriously has put
together every noise you make not every
noise I beg to differ
I think we're about here I'm gonna every
noise you made it takes a little while
you can shut your eyes so you'll enjoy
this this is the vocal stylings of
Keeley hauls ass Lara Croft someone
who's taking the time to set this
together falling off a cliff death in a
second
she's done
drew barrymore she made the mistake of
giving me notes which I would you take
that was sort of artificial because it
was the nap I was the actress playing
the front attendance woman yeah at the
same time I was an American actress
playing the British woman